deux semaines consacrées à la musique et
à la chanson francophone c'est la
mission depuis 35 ans de l'Estival
Juliette Armanet Émile et image ou
encore Yannick Noah le festival à vibrer
cette année au rythme d'une
programmation diversifiée l'Estival en
fait c'est 3 axes c'est un festival de
chanson francophone mais qui permet à
toutes les musiques de pouvoir
s'exprimer ensuite c'est un festival qui
met en lumière les jeunes talents
participation à des premières parties
des podiums et des vitrines découvertes
comme hier et puis troisième axe on
donne un coup de projecteur sur une
association caritative et humanitaire et
cette année ces BBS bar des bielles
syndrome des rendez-vous musicaux qui se
déroulent dans les villes de Poissy à
chair Houilles le PEC Montesson et
Conflans-Sainte-Honorine l'occasion de
donner un coup de projecteur sur des
artistes prometteurs du territoire ce
jour-là c'était le power trio de rock
français non adoc qui jouait sur la la
base de la République
c'est une super programmation dans le
coin et comme nous on a un groupe local
et que là c'est la mise en valeur
justement de scène un petit peu locale
c'est un festival qui est francophone
quoi pour la musique francophone et ça
c'est ça c'est top parce qu'on a une
super scène en France qui est pas
nécessairement toujours mise en valeur
des concerts qui semblent également
ravir le public heureux de pouvoir
revenir au concert après plusieurs
années compliquées
comme ça là quand on est en bulle ben ça
accroche ça accrocheur on a envie
d'entendre ce qu'ils disent et parce que
vachement sympa j'aime bien c'est ça
change un petit peu de ce qu'on a
l'habitude d'entendre dans ce style de
musique ça permet aussi de découvrir pas
mal de lieux vraiment ce qui se passe du
coin c'est vrai que je découvre pas mal
de de d'endroits et c'est le format est
cool enfin le fait que ce soit sur trois
semaines un festival qui reviendra pour
sa 36e édition l'année prochaine
quelques noms résonne déjà dans les
oreilles des organisateurs